hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the chess.com Global
Championship 2022 it's The Knockouts the
qualifications for the main event that
will take place sometime in November I I
think on the 2nd of November it starts
but um not really sure but it's the game
that we are interested in and what's
funny is that uh here nihal sarin faces
dingler and one of the candidates of the
next World Championship match and also
uh Timo rajaba faces Johnny Palm Nashid
the other candidate of the World Chess
Championship match so uh they are uh
obviously nihal and rajable are The
Underdogs so what happens is a very very
awesome and I will put a link to the
entire article if you guys want to see
the other games as well will be the
first link in the description below now
let's check it out ding has the white
pieces and he opens with D4 we have Pawn
to D5 C4 E6 sorry about that
uh Knight the C3 and here an eagle goes
for the very sharp C5 the taraj defense
and we have C counters on D5 and now if
you want to be a very adventurous you
will play something like C captures on
D4 but this is a dingler and we are
talking about so better place solid e
captures on D5 Knight to F3 we have
Knight to F6 and Bishop to G5 so all all
standards have the two knights variation
of the tarash uh Bishop to E6 and now
phone to E3 and now the main moves here
are Knights the C6 and C for C4 uh is
not as much played as nice to C6 but I
believe it's to be uh the the more
annoying move to face and now comes the
bishop to E2 now it's very interesting
as black pretty much abandoned the fight
for the center by playing this uh sort
of anti-positional C4 idea what happens
if white just strikes in the center with
E4 as I mean if it can be played it
should be played and the thing is it's
incredibly complicated for example D
captures an E4 yeah white even has the
option of D5 and now we have Bishop to
G4
pinning the attacked piece H3 Bishop to
h5g for Bishop to be G6 and now Knight
the H4 where black will get this very
nice developing Bishop to C5 and you can
even capture for example captures
captures and Bishop captures and C4
Blackwell castle and okay white is up
material but black already played h3g
for the king is an E1 so while it
probably can be played I don't think
anyone wants to play this because after
C for E4 has only been played once and
white lost that game so here Bishop to
E2 this is the main continuation uh top
move recommended by the engine at Knight
B to D7 and now we have Castles by ding
with Bishop to B4 and now there are uh
there is a game where Knight D2 was
played but here a dingo's night the E5
and it is now as of move 10 that we have
a completely new game already uh with
with some very nice ideas so here at
nihal just castles and now comes Knight
captures on D7 and this is the idea
behind the E5 saying that you can't
capture with the Knight because the
queen hangs and you cannot capture with
the bishop because then the D5 Pawn
hangs the Knight is pinned by the bishop
so you have to play Queen characters on
D7 and this allows ding to open up
nihal's King's side so Bishop captures
on F6 G captures and now Queen to F3
putting pressure on the D5 Pawn
and white never really is worried about
captures because then white will capture
with the B Pawn Big Pawn becomes C Pawn
the more powerful Center is is formed
and so on so here just King G7 and now
you will have options of maybe even
bringing Rooks to the G file but also
Justice For example the queen occupies
this diagonal you you will not have to
worry about that so here we have A4 and
now Pawn to B6 we have Knight to E2 now
bringing the Knight to F4 as black does
not have a e Pawn or a g Pawn to kick
away the Knight we have Bishop to D6
stopping Knight to F4 and now Knight
back to C3 biting putting again pressure
on the D5 pawn and again Bishop to B4 so
ding is asking nihal is asking what do
you what do you want to play here really
so Queen to C2 and now Rook a to C8 we
have Rook F to D1 and now Pawn to F5 and
okay uh wants some space here but for
the moment his Bishop is pretty much a
pawn so so we'll he will have to figure
out how to get past this with G3 keeping
that pawn on F5 you do not want to see
F4 played uh Pawn to A6 and now we have
Knight to E2 now the Knight again has
some ideas of coming to F4 and nihal
again plays Bishop to D6 we have B3 now
challenging the spawn structure and B5 a
cat versus a captors and now B captures
and C4 and now you would expect nehal to
play B captures and C4 promote his B
Pawn to a c pawn it will be a pass Pawn
The Rook is already behind it but nihal
plays Rook captures on C Pawn on c for
attacking the queen and probably with
the idea that he can push the pawn to B4
at some point he will also double up the
Rooks on the C file so the only thing
nihal has to figure out is how to make
the slide Square Bishop an actual piece
so Queen to B3 getting the queen out of
the way and now Rook F to C8 nicely
doubling up on the C file Rook to A5
going after the B5 pawn and now Rook the
B4 attacking ding's Queen and here ding
should probably play something like
Queen to D3 but he played Queen to A2
and this allows nikal uh the very
forcing Rook to A4 now you have to trade
Rooks here and nihal gets the outside
passed Pawn so capras captures now the
pass Pawn is very strong and this even
comes with a pawn sacrifice but nikal
wants to think the capture on D5 but if
he doesn't capture on D5 uh what else do
you have to show for uh for allowing the
nihal this beautiful past tape on so
ding captures the pawn here we have Pawn
to A3 and now Bishop captures an E6 we
have Queen captures offering a queen
trade and now ding just plays Pawn to D5
we have Queen to E4 and here we have a
beautiful position where pretty much
only one move is the safe move for ding
but he doesn't find it here ding plays
Knights the D4 and Knight the D4 makes
sense here by playing Knight to D4 ding
wants to put the Knight to the C 6 this
takes away the C file from the rook and
also covers the B8 Square so also takes
the B file from The Rook but instead of
this a move that had to be played was
Queen to A1 with check and it's such a
funny line that I believe you guys uh
should see it for example King G8 now
Queen to F6 and once the pawn comes to
A2 as this is what you want to do queen
G5 check King to f8 and now Queen to H6
with check if you go to the corner
obviously you'll give white too many
chances King D7 Queen to G5 check King
the E8 the Queen the G8 check and now
Bishop to f8 pawn to D6 and now we have
Rook the d8 of course you can't do
anything with the Apon just yet because
D7 check is coming so Rook to d8 and not
Knight the C3 attacking the queen and
the pawn Rook captures on D6 now saying
okay you capture the pawn I'm gonna play
real characters on D1 Checkmate so and
of course uh you can't really uh capture
The Rook because then A1 just cleans the
pawn so here Rook the A1 and now Queen
the F3 yeah putting pressure on that D1
square and now Queen to h8 and now Point
uh Pawn to F6 blocking the Queen's uh
diagonal Rook captures an A2 and now
Rook the D1 check Knight captures Queen
captures and now finally after King to
G2 Queen to D5 check connecting with the
Rook King to G1 Queen captures an A2 and
now Queen captures an A7 this is one of
the possibilities where nikal would be
up a bishop but ding would be up two
points basically three pawns as the F
Pawn is doubled so with the King wide in
the open there's no way you are avoiding
checks here so all in all uh a very long
draw but this was the absolute best that
Ding could play but instead he played
Knight to D4 and now there is a problem
I already kind of gave you a hint what
the idea behind Knight to D4 is but
having that in mind do you see the
absolute best move for nihal while I
give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing that
night the C6 simply cannot be allowed
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is Rook the B8 and it
even comes with an exclamation mark As I
downloaded the PGN straight from
chess.com so yeah it kind of you know
stays there uh but yeah it's a very nice
exclamation mark and now uh how are you
stopping Rook the B2 is coming and that
is extremely annoying so here at night
the B3 stopping that and now Queen to C4
putting pressure on the Knight here and
being just plays Knight to C1 or rather
he doesn't Knight the C1 is one of the
options that's uh that's that's a nice
one but even if this is played let's say
cat first captures and Rook B2 there's
just no good way to play this for
example Rook to A1 you just play Bishop
E5 and now there's nothing you can do
whatever you play let's say H3 just Rook
D2 Now The Rook is hanging the Knight is
hanging and there's no way out of this
so instead Queen to A1 was check which
is a good move only it should have been
played some three moves ago we have King
to G6 now another very nice move by
nikal the king is much safer here now
Knight the A5 attacking the queen here
and just Queen to e to nihal that puts
the queen uh here to to a very very a
nice square and now there is nothing uh
dink can uh do here uh Rook the B2 is
coming and that's just gonna be
overwhelming you're gonna have constant
pressure on F2 A2 is coming it's just uh
an Unstoppable uh attack by black so it
didn't plays Rook to E1 and now of
course we have the move from the
thumbnail and that is Queen captures on
E1 just eliminating one of the uh
Defenders of the of the back rank Queen
captures anyone and just Pawn to A2 and
it was in this position on move 36 that
dingler and resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
Anika won another very nice game against
the ding and he didn't even need the
full four games to take the win at do
was uh two wins was sufficient so yeah
here you resign because there's not all
that much you can do Rook the B1 is
coming you you cannot stop this even if
you try if you try a queen to A1 then
Rook to B1 comes with check so that's
not working any flicking the G2 again
Rook to B1 and you're just promoting the
pawn to a queen let's say queen C3 A1
Queen you will have to trade captures
captures but now you are just up a full
Rook so of course this is completely
unplayable so after a dilding resigned
and a wonderful wonderful victory for
nihal sarin and like I said they were a
job of a facing and he defeated the
anime so basically nikal and our job of
uh kicked out the the World Chess
Championship
um uh candidates who who will play the
World Chess Championship Match next year
uh doing a nipple so that's uh I mean uh
pretty pretty incredible and no one
thought it could be done but they did
just that uh so yeah that's the game and
a little bit of info on what's going on
in the chess.com Global Championship the
The Knockouts this was the last match so
uh next is um the the main event in the
in November so stay tuned for that uh I
would like to thank Alan winner Len
Herbert congratulations Dr kako Francis
air and Ashish jairman for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions uh and whatever
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day